It seems like all processed foods are terrible…
but might they actually be saving your life?
When talking processed foods, my mind immediately
jumps to pastries, ready to eat frozen meals
and soda pops… but that’s only part of
the picture.
Processed foods are really anything that’s
been altered or modified from its original
state.
Think of how many food items have salts or
sugar added, or have been smoked, cooked,
packaged or canned in preservatives - these
are all considered processed.
Basically, if it’s not a whole apple or
plain nut, it’s probably processed.
So clearly, if the definition of “processed”
is that broad, processing isn’t always bad
for you - in fact, processing can make food
safer.
Pasteurization, for example, kills harmful
bacteria in milk and juice, which makes them
safer for consumption.
Freezing counts as processing too, and in
addition to fighting bacterial growth, it
actually helps foods preserve their nutrients.
This is all why some scientists decided it
didn’t make sense to lump all processed
foods together.
Doing so muddles results in studies and as
a consequence, allows big food companies to
make claims that are in their best interests.
So, scientists have separated out the real
villains under the term ultra-processed.
Carlos Augusto Monteiro, leading researcher
at the Centre for Epidemiological Studies
in Health and Nutrition at the University
of São Paulo defines “ultra-processed”
as foods that fall into the ready to eat and
ready to heat buckets.
Think of an aluminum wrapped energy bar or
a burger at a junk food joint.
He explains that these foods are made up of
multiple minimally processed foods.
And, they’re typically processed further
through baking or frying, they have more additives,
they’re packaged or canned, and they have
more added salt, sugar, vitamins, minerals.
Actually - a LOT more: a typical ultra-processed
meal contains 33% more sugar and 25% more
salt and fat than a meal comprised of natural
and minimally processed foods.
You probably already know why these foods,
and what’s in them, are bad for you.
Sugar is linked to obesity, diabetes and artificial
sugars are linked to cancer, weight gain,
and mess with your metabolism.
Added fats - especially trans fats, are linked
to coronary heart disease.
And you may also know that processes like
refining carbohydrates can lead to overeating,
and insulin spikes.
But ultra-processed foods also contain less
of important things, like fiber.
Which is a problem because besides decreasing
your risk of diabetes and aiding in digestion,
fiber helps you feel full.
Not enough fiber, and you’re more likely
to overeat.
Add to this that ultra-processed foods are
more energy dense, and it means that on top
of eating more calories, you’re eating the
wrong kind.
And this matters because consumption of ultra-processed
foods is increasing, and these foods are replacing
other less processed foods in the U.S., and
abroad . While lots of processed foods are
good for you, NO ultra-processed food is healthful.
Now this doesn’t mean we shouldn’t have
pizza, ever.
But it does mean we should be vigilant about
quantity and quality when making food choices
as a whole.
When choosing meats, Trace has the run down
in this episode.
Check it out
to learn more about how processed meats can
cause you harm.